-Welcome back, Natasha.
-Thanks, Seth.
-Congratulations on the show.
It's really something special.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-For those who haven't seen it,
the premise is --
you are a woman,
on her 36th birthday,
who keeps dying and then going
back and reliving that birthday.
over and over again.
-Yeah. It's essentially sort of
an existential adventure show,
involving multiple loops
and deaths.
And it's hilarious.
You're going to love it.
You're really going to enjoy it.
-But it has been a show that --
Everyone I know has seen it,
we like talking about it.
We like trying to
deconstruct it.
Are you surprised that you made
an existential adventure show,
as you said, and people
have been so drawn to it?
-I mean, I am.
And, in the first place, I would
say I'm also --
You know, I'm blown away.
It's so, you know,
definitively personal to me
that I am very moved that
it's connecting on this level.
And, yes, I definitely think
it's indicative of
the troubling times we're in
that it's connected
for so many
other people, as well.
It's essentially a show
that's saying,
"Hey, we're all broken
on the inside.
Let's do it together."
-Which is
a really lovely message.
And I should say, because this
is eight episodes on Netflix
and the highest praise
I can have for it is --
it starts great and ends better.
Because I feel like there are
shows where people say,
"You've got to give it
five episodes."
And I want to say,
"I have a life."
Whereas this starts great,
and then you can say to people,
"Oh, stick around,
because they know
exactly where they're going."
And because this isn't just this
very personal autobiographical
show that you helped create,
there is also -- There is,
like, a science-fiction element
and a plotting element that
you guys took very seriously.
This is like "A Beautiful Mind."
There you go.
-There you go.
This is fully
from the writers's room
of getting all
the time lines straight.
-And this is actually
Michael Bricker,
the wonderful
production designer,
who had a hell of a time,
because what he was
doing here is --
you know, he's managing
loops and time lines
and multiple deaths.
Our poor script supervisor,
Melissa Yap.
I mean, she came from
"Orange is the New Black."
She's amazing.
And this was an endless game.
It was almost like, you know,
Jodie Foster searching
for Hannibal Lecter,
only she didn't even know that
she was looking for
Hannibal at the time.
I mean, it's a real, you know,
cross-sectioning scenario.
-And, yet, you drew from,
you know,
this very personal place
and you drew from your life.
And I've known you for a long
time, and I've always --
You know,
we know each other well.
-Then you know I'm a big fan
of Viktor Frankl's
"Man's Search for Meaning,"
so -- Yes.
-But I've always felt --
And I feel like
maybe other people
feel this way, too.
I always felt like I knew you
better than I did,
because I feel as though
you're a very open person
and I feel like maybe
that's one of the things
people are responding to
in this show is --
they can tell,
"Oh, I've seen Natasha in things
over the years
and I've liked her,
but this is
the purest version of her
I've ever seen of her onscreen."
-Yeah, I mean,
I think that that's --
You know, just speaking frankly,
because I do know you,
I mean, that's the,
sort of, like, heavy part
to take in, you know,
as somebody who has been
working in this thing
for a long time.
You know, I started show biz
back before
anybody here was born,
including me.
And so it's just so,
you know, heavy and deep that,
you know, something so personal
is connecting in this way.
But, yeah, you know, I mean,
it's a lot of connective tissue.
We had such an incredible room,
and there's so many creators.
Your friend Amy Poehler,
of course, co-created the show
and Leslye Headland.
And we had all female writers
and directors on the show.
So I think it was really --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
So, I do think it was also
sort of, kind of like
a testament to what happens
if you just, you know,
try to avoid small talk, like I
do desperately, in this life
and sort of aim to kind of
tell your version of
the truth, you know?
-You now -- I know how
you feel about small talk.
I would assume, because you made
this very personal show,
people feel a comfort
to come up and talk to you.
And now they probably want to
talk to you about this show,
which is great for you,
because that's not
small talk anymore.
-And, yet, you know,
the great relief is --
I think I'm sort of like
a Paul Giamatti type.
-What does that mean?
-You know what it means.
It's like, you know,
you see Paul Giamatti,
you're thrilled, but you're not
going to go up to him
and be, like, "Hey,
'American Splendor' was great."
I mean, where does it go?
It's like we all know --
But it's kind of like
a New York character
that's more like a garden gnome
or a leprechaun.
A twin. A twin even.
-I see.
-I'm happy to kind of see you.
I think I may be projecting
an air of like,
"Hey, buddy,
I might follow you home,
so why don't you --" Right?
I'm not even doing it
on purpose.
I just might
follow you home, you know?
-No, I think there is
something true
about the quintessential
New York celebrity
that because they're
so New York and the fact
that they have stayed there
for their career,
they're -- They don't --
-You begin is what it is, Seth.
You begin to blend into
the pavement.
You're like a series of ash
piles on the street.
-No. I figure people are like,
"Natasha Lyonne is so New York
that because of
her New Yorkness,
she probably doesn't want
a stranger to come up
and ask for a selfie."
-Eh, it'd be nice
once in a while.
Will you?
A little, "Hey, nice job,"
you know,
give me 5 bucks, whatever.